Jean Moulin il est pas né à Raba
d'accord Charles de Gaulle euh pareil
c'est un français donc c'est pas les
musulmans qui ont sauvé la France c'est
les Français qui ont sauvé la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
France la guerre est un drame
elle est un drame pour ceux qui l'a fond
et elle est un drame pour ceux qui la
subissent maintenant qui est responsable
de de cette situation qui est
responsable des roquettes qui tombent
aujourd'hui sur la ville de Gaza c'est
le Hamas c'est le Hamas qui précisément
utilise est-ce que c'est vrai que ils
ont voulu ils ont le SAL a voulu livrer
300 l de carburant et que ils sont pas
arrivés parce que je je suis pas je n'ai
aucune information à ce sujet je pense
qu'il faut être l'information c'est
aussi un enjeu en T être très prudent
sur les mais mais qui utilise
aujourd'hui des gens dans une
les écoles les mosquées les hôpitaux
comme des boucliers humains qui met ses
quartiers généraux sous les mosquées les
écoles les hôpitaux c'est le Hamas qu'on
voit c'est qu'il y a des civils qui sont
pris en qui sont pris dans dans une
guerre voilà et qui qui qui qui vivent
des moments très compliqués aussi vous
vous mais évidemment voilà vous mais non
mais attendez bien sûr et c'est pour ça
que je crois que le rôle de la France
c'est d'avoir une position qui soit une
position raisonnable une position
constante c'est de faire tout le
contraire de ce que fait Emmanuel Macron
c'estàd de changer la vie toutes les 24
heuresé au Parlement européen en faveur
de pauses humanitaires je pense qu'il
faut des pauses humanitaires pour
permettre justement au civils d'être le
plus à l'abri possible et j'ai dit
depuis le départ que la réponse d'Israël
qui est légitime sur le fond elle doit
être le plus ciblé possible pour
protéger les populations innocentes mais
je n'oublie pas de rappeler que ceux qui
sont responsable de ces attaques c'est
le Hamas on n'est pas là entre deux
armées on a une armée d'un État
démocratique et en face une organisation
terroriste qui envoie non pas des
soldats combattre mais des soldats prêts
à mourir et faire le J ne qualifie pas
le Hamas de de groupe terroriste vous
lui répondz non mais Jean-Luc Mélenchon
la France insoumise pourrait s'appeler
la France islamiste c'est que Monsieur
Mélenchon il épouse toutes les thèses
des fondamentalistes islamistes quand on
a une députée madame obono qui est
membre de la France insoumise qui
s'exprime en disant que le Hamas n'est
pas une organisation terroriste mais un
mouvement de résistance on a tout dit le
rêve de Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est et
c'est très irrespectueux pour eux
d'ailleurs il pensent que en étant le
plus le plus tolérant à l'égard du
terrorisme le plus tolérant à l'égard de
l'idéologie islamiste il pourrait avoir
le vote des Français de confessions
musulmanes dans les Bonlieu donc le plus
cynique dans cette affaire c'est lui et
c'est son mouvement qui je crois a perdu
toute forme d'honneur et qui qui est
très irresponsable sur la forme vous
vous souvenez que pendant les émeutes au
mois de juillet Monsieur Mélenchon avait
refusé d'appeler au calme il avait
attendu 3 jours pour demander simplement
de ne pas euh euh attaquer les
bibliothèques ou les les centres
documentaires et moi ce qui m'a frappé
dans la manifestation d'hier c'est que
quand en fait c'est pas les amis de
Monsieur Mélenchon qui organise des
manifestations ça se passe bien il y a
pas de slogan antiflic il y a pas de
casse il y a pas d'abribus dégradé il y
a pas de policiers qui sont prêts à
partir les cafés peuvent continuer
d'être ouvert et c'est ça au fond la
différence entre des gens qui sont
responsables qui sont dignes qui sont
sains et des gens qui sont des
incendiaires et qui sont représent Mo un
danger pour la République França on voir
David Guer il était en Tunisie ce
vendredi il a fait énormément parler de
lui ça fait une grosse grosse polémique
c'était une conférence intitulée peut-on
encore défendre les Palestiniens en
France regardez et vous me dites ce que
vous en pensez regardez les le bébé dans
le
four rendez-vous compte quand même que
les médias diffusent ces informations il
y a aucun m Culp moi je suis sûr qu'il y
en aura un dans un ou 2 ans quand ça
sera un petit peu passé et que ça
coûtera pas cher en fait symboliquement
politiquement économiquement de dire on
a fauté ah vraiment c'était c'était pas
top mais en attendant ils retransmettent
ces éléments là le bébé dans le four ça
a été fait en effet par
Israël la maman est ventrée ça ça a été
fait c'est vrai par
Israël honteux c'est chaud alors chaud
monsieur guirud est le porte-parole du
Hamas que ce qu'il dit c'est la
propagande des terroristes islamistes du
Hamas qu'on massacré des civils et
j'espère que Monsieur guirot sera cette
semaine à l'Assemblée nationale quand
madame Bron Pivet va diffuser les 43
minutes d'images qui qui ont été
récupéré par l'armée israéliennes et qui
vont être diffusés des images des
massacres moi je vais vous dire euh je
les ai on me les a envoyé les images
massacre d'accord je les ai regardé
parce que je pense qu'il faut voir ce
qui se passe il faut voir ce dont sont
capablebles me les envoyer également des
gens aujourd'hui c'est pas un choc de
civilisation entre les musulmans les
Juifs les Chrétiens c'est un un choc des
mondes entre la civilisation et la
barbarie parce que ce que font ces gens
c'est de la barbarie et Monsieur guireot
voyez il il joue la la l'incendiaire
depuis son salon c'estàd queil est dans
son salon il est dans des salons feutrés
là partout je sais pas où il est en
vacances en Tunisie et il joue en fait à
alimenter le conflit mais c'est pas
monsieur guireud qui va aller en
première ligne pour aller défendre mais
moi j'invite à faire ça si si si veut
défendre la population à Gaza s'il veut
défendre les terroristes du Hamas et
bien qu'il aille sur place et qu'il soit
courageux au point d'aller au bout et là
je pense qu'il y aura un peu moins de
monde à l'aéroport alors ou Gill non
David guireot c'est inacceptable en plus
il se trompe il impute à Israël les
massacres des camps de Sabra Chatila
c'était des des falanges
chrétien voilà il se voilà bon il se
trompent mais moi j'ai j'ai j'ai une
question à vous poser là vous venez de
dire qu'il aille là-bas pour voir les
populations palestiniennes et le Hamas
en fait vous mêlez toujours les deux
quand le président de la République
appelle à un cesser le feu c'est pour
protéger les populations palestiniennes
et arrêter le massacre des populations
palestiniennes de Gaza ça vous n'en
voulez pas en tant commomme d'état vous
ne voulez pas de ça non mais en tant
qu'omme d'État je connais le droit de la
guerre et le cesser le feu en droit de
la guerre c'est l'interruption des
combats entre deux armées ce qu'il faut
c'est des pauses humanitaires pour
permettre à la population de Gaza d'être
ravitaillé mais je peux vous dire que
votre cess le feu il fait qu'un seul
ravi c'est le Hamas parce que le Hamas
il attend qu'une chose c'est que les
frappes israéliennes et l'intervention
de tsal cessent pour pouvoir se
ravitailler pour pouvoir faire rentrer
de l'argent dans Gaza pour pouvoir faire
rentrer des munitions des armes encore
plus puissante pour mener l'offensive
contre Israël moi je n'ai aucune forme
de tolérance à l'égard du du Hamas donc
on peut se disputer sur les mot
dispz est-ce que vous condamnez le
massacre des populations civiles de Gaza
oui je l'ai dit depuis le départ la
réponse israélienne doit être le plus
ciblée possible maintenant ce que je
condamne moi à la rigueur ça n'a aucune
impact moi ce que je ce que je souhaite
faire comme responsable politique
français c'est protéger mes compatriotes
et protéger mes concitoyens de
l'importation sur le seul français de ce
conflit et de dire à mes concitoyens que
l'idéologie du Hamas elle est déjà sur
le territoire de la République française
et encore une fois c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure demander à nos
compatriotes de confession juives de
quoi ils ont peur aujourd'hui ils ont
peur non pas là-bas mais ici
concrètement dans leur immeuble dans
leur cage d'escalier et et chez eux
maintenant vous savez il faut beaucoup
de modestie sur cette situation c'est
pas nous sur le plateau qu'allons
résoudre un conflit qui dure depuis 70
ans sur lequel toutes les grandes
puissances se sont cassées les dents et
toutes les initiatives de paix qui ont
été menées y compris par les grandes
puissance et notamment les accords de
d'Oslo au début des années 90 ont échoué
et Raymond Haron qui disait l'histoire
est tragique disait aussi qu'il y a
parfois le père des relations
internationales disait parfois qu'il y a
certains conflits dans le monde qui sont
inexpiables et je je pense que celui-ci
en tout cas doit nous appeler à beaucoup
de modestie Jordan mardella donc la LFI
était pas là Jean-Luc ménanchon n'était
pas la marche organiser une autre marche
contre l'antisémitisme organisation d'un
rassemblement dit oui monsieur me dit
quelque chose derrière les otages que
plus personne ne parle des otages on
sait qu'il y a des négociations
aujourd'hui qui sont en cours et et on a
oublié d'ailleurs hier en disant que la
marche était pas une marche pour
dénoncer l'antisémitisme c'était aussi
une marche pour penser au aux otages qui
sont encore aujourd'hui français
européens ou de toute nationalité détenu
dans la bande de Gaza et évidemment aux
40 de nos concitoyens aux 40 français
qui ont perdu la vie dans les programmes
du 7 octobre dernier alors donc il y a
une autre marche enfin ils ont créé la
polémique au veldive la France insmis on
rappelle avait décidé de boycotter la
marche contre l'antisémitisme qui
réunissait tous les partis leur excuse
il ne voulaient pas défiler à côté de
vouson ça j'aurais été très mal à l'aise
moi de de manifester je leuri fait hein
voilà nous quand la République nous nous
convoque on répond à son appel mais
j'aurais été très mal à l'aise
de manifester à côté de Monsieur guireud
ou à côté de Monsieur Mélenchon qui
justifie en fait le pire et qui justifie
la barbarie alors justement de nombreux
militants dont des familles déporté ont
dénoncé une récupération indécente et
c'est vrai que l'accueil pour la France
insoumise n'a pas été fou
[Musique]
regardezouou
alors Gill ver juste petite question
vous comprenez la décision de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon de ne pas aller à la marche ah
oui ah oui tout à fait mais mais mais je
m'exprime en mon nom propre moi je vais
pas au marche mais je n'uris non non
mais jeanluc mélchon oui parce que moi
je n'aurais pas marché au côté de
Monsieur Bardella sor du plateau alors
parce que ah oui c'est vrai non alors
attendez je précise quand
mêmeou marcher contre l'antimitis non
mais faire le théâtre sur le plateau de
télé auun problème c'est une vraie
question je réponds ouis je vais vous le
dire honnêtement quand on a débattu ici
même une fois j'avais une question à
vous posé sur une affaire judiciaire en
dehors du plateau vous avez toujours été
extrêmement courtois vous débattez je
n'ai aucun problème mais je ne marcherai
pas avec vous
jamais je pas en mourir laiss mais je
sais que vous allez pas mourir vous non
plus si tuas un gros traget qui veut
déposer en voiture tu fais quoi j'ai une
question à vous poser si on marchait
contre l'antisémitisme qui est un fléo
un délit absolu et contre l'islamophobie
qui est un fléo absolu est-ce que vous
marcheriez avec moi combien de morts de
l'islamophobie combi vous êtes pas prof
et je suis pas votre
élève combien monsieur ver il a combien
de de l'islam ob depuis 15 ans dans
notre pays donc vous répondez non non
mais je vous pose une question ah oui
mais moi je vous en ai posé une vous me
répondez pas monur non mais parce que
j'ai pas forcément envie de répondre à
vous vous poser mais j'aimerais
comprendre votre question combien de
morts sous les balles et les lames du
fondamentalisme islamiste depuis plus de
10 ans depuis 2012 combien de morts de
l'islamophobie dans notre société
l'islamophobie ça sert à mettre des
cibles et des fatois sur la tête de ceux
qui dénoncent aujourd'hui les
territoires conquis par l'islamisme sur
la tête de journalistes ont le
courage ah bon non ça permet de mettre
des cibles sur la tête de ceux qui
dénoncent aujourd'hui de ceux qui comme
Charlie hebbdo se sont permis de faire
vivre cette esprit critique et cet
esprit de liberté l'islamophobie les
procès en islamophobie ça sert à mettre
des cibles sur les gens qui refusent de
voir l'islamisme conquérir l'espace
public et conquérir la société française
donc mais je vous je ne vous accuse de
rien monsieur verd je vous pose une
question vous ne me répondez pas combien
de morts de l'islamophobie en France
donc vous pouvez pas mettre sur le
mêmelamophobie et l'antisémtis qui a tué
des dizaines et des dizaines de nos
compatriotes a commencé par des enfants
de l'école au zaratora en 2012 où
Mohamed Mera avec un scooter est rentré
et et a tiré sur des enfants il a
attrapé des enfants par tête il leur a
tiré une balle dans la tête c'est ça la
réalité l'antisém au en pour une marche
nationale contre contre l'islamophobie
et l'antisémitisme répondez-moi et je
vous répondrai si vous me dites demain
on marche contre l'antisémitisme et
contre le mauvais temps c'est c'est ça a
pas de sens combien de morts
répondez-moi combien il y a eu une mort
de l'islamopob tue ça tue la
civilisation Fran
islamophobque tu peux dire contre
l'antisémitisme et les clichés contre
les musulmans peut-être aussi très bien
en penses très bien voulez que je marche
contre les clichés ouais si on fait ça
je marche avec vous et il m'en
coûte vous m paraissez un peu
perch voulez pas attendez mais c'est
très juste pour comprendre voulez pas
marcher
pouroi avec moi je suis responsable de
laée d'un éventuelle islamobie je
dénonce votre hypocrisie c'est tout
c'est que H il y a vous qui la voyez là
je sais pas si d'autres vis mais c'est
vrai que comme dit qu' ne manifeste
jamais manifester après
Charlie ils en sont mors des fis sur
l'islamophobtiv ne veut pas y aller hier
alors que c'était justement justement
pour la République pour no vurs commune
et je comprends pas pourquoi il sera
allé dans le cas où il y avait une autre
cause en fait non je suggérais à
Monsieur Bardella éventuellement cette
marche générale seul argumentaire ton
seul argumentaire concernant cette
marche c'est de dire précisément que tu
ne peux pas marcher contre
l'antisémitisme et que tu ne peut le
faire que si on marche contre
l'antisémitisme et l'islamophobie si
c'est la réalité c'est ta réponse et ça
veut tout dire de la société
d'aujourd'hui ça veut tout dire de qui é
et ben oui mais ça veut tout dire de qui
était à cette marche hier c'était une
partie de la France c'était pas tout la
France il y a une vraie fracture moi je
je franchement je pense que notre pays
meurt aujourd'hui euh de gens qui ont
toujours une bonne excuse pour pas donc
des gens comme moi ouais un peu un peu
je je vous le dis ça de manière
totalement courtoise mais mais si vous
voulez vu ce qu'on a vécu là depuis 2012
vu ce qui s'est passé en Israël vu ce
que subissent aujourd'hui les Français
de confession juives d'aller dire je
vais pas marcher en fait contre
l'antisémitisme parce qu'il y a pas
antisémitisme mais islamophobie par que
vous êtes là ça m'a paraît un peu léger
mais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait moi c'est
moi qui est reste qui c'est c'est moi
qui tient qui compare le m un mouvement
de résistance je trouve qu'acord c'est
moi qui qui qui fait que les Français de
confessions juives aujourd'hui sont
contraains de retirer les noms des boîes
aux lettres Gill en 2019 Mélenchon il il
a fait un tweet où il dit à la fin quand
je participe à une marche je regarde les
idées pas ceux qui sont dedans qu'est-ce
qui a changé depuis 2019 mais je suis
pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon je trouve ça
dommage que vous souhaaitiez diviser les
Français voilà et je trouve que par un
populisme un peu simple vous voulez
diviser les Français entre eux et je
pense que la division n n'est pas bonne
dans le temps des des tempêtes que vit
la France aujourd'hui ce qui s'est passé
à Lyon vous avez vu vous avez vu ou pas
on va reevoir ce qui s'est passé
regarder vous allez dire ce que vous en
pensez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Jordan
attaqué alors donc c'était une réunion
pour la Palestine qui a été perturbé par
des par un mouvement d'ultra droite vous
condamnez ça ou pas oui je condamne
d'ailleurs tous les les les mouvements
qui utilisent la violence qui soit
d'ultra gauche aux ultra droite et je
pense que la démocratie c'est
précisément le le pouvoir des la
violence des mots c'est que là on a le
droit de pas être d'accord on a le droit
je pas vous dire on a le droit d'être
dur dans les termes parce que c'est ça
la dé et en fait en étant très dur dans
des échanges qu'on peut avoir ensemble
ça évite de recourir à la viol et c'est
ça la démocratie et je pense que ceux
qui ne la comprennent pas qu'il soit
d'ultra droite ou d'ultra gauche doivent
évidemment tomber sous le coup de sous
le coup de la loi en l'occurrence être
dissous Jean-Marie Le Pen il est été
antisémite ou pas il s'est évidemment
enfermé dans un dans un antisémitisme
dans des provocations antisém antisémit
pardonnez-moi qui ont amené en 2015 il y
a près d'une décennie maintenant à ce
que Marine Le Pen présidente du Front
national engage une rupture politique
avec son propre père mais moi ce que je
trouve dommage c'est qu'on est passé une
semaine ou mais c'estm à parler de
Jean-Marie Le Pen oui mais c'est 95 ans
qui en plus ne peut pas se défendre je
le je je veux bien que ce soit le jeu
mais mais je pense qu'on a assez perdre
du temps comme ça et voyez vous avez
répondu donc vous le dites voilà vous
l'avez vous avez répondu clairement ce
soir ou B il été condamné par la justice
en fait pour aller au bout de allons au
bout on a utilisé sur une heure
d'interview j'ai une maladresse en
répondant à un journaliste et de cette
maladresse j'en ai fait j'en ferai quand
vous êtes en politique en première ligne
et ben vous êtes forcément amené parfois
à avoir des mots qui sont mal
interprétés mal
àroit c'est une maladresse non du Rafour
crématoire c'est une maladresse ce que
vous dites est de la malhonnêteté parce
que je n'ai jamais dit cela vous me
dites on a extrait d'une d'une interview
mais vous l'avez écouté l'interview où
je dis que les propos de sur le point de
détail oui bien sûr je parle de mon
interview voilà moi c'est c'est mais
encore une fois si vous voulez moi je
suis né en 95 j'ai rejoint le Front
national en 2012 et je je je je l'ai
croisé trois fois trois fois dans ma vie
donc j'ai vu ce que ce que vous avez dit
effectivement c'est à vomir et si tu me
permets Cyril s'il te plaît j'aimerais
faire une lettre d'excuses justement à
Madame levvy moi en tant que Français de
confession musulmane et si tu me laisses
une minute j'irai au plus rapide madame
Levy nous musulmans on s'excuse c'est
vrai on s'excuse d'avoir sauvé la France
lors de la deuxième guerre mondiale
conquise en 3 jours seulement par le
nazisme lors du blit
Kake nous sommes allés au front avec des
prières qui visiblement ne dérangeaient
personne à cette époque-là pendant que
la majorité des Français collaborait
bien à l'abri et qu'une
infine minorité de héros résistait
difficilement tant la délation
svissait nous musulmans madame Lévi on
s'excuse on s'excuse parce que l'imam de
la mosquée de
Paris Abdelkader Mesli qui a sauvé des
Juifs de la xénophobie du gouvernement
il abritait les déclaré à l'autorité
comme musulman pour les protéger
regardez-moi s'il vous plaît non écoutez
je vais vous regarder mais il a risqué
sa vie pour celle d'autui pour des
autres qui pensaient différemment de lui
il a été à la guestapo ça c'est un nom
qui doit vous parler sûrement torturé
puis déporté à dacho vous connaissez ça
aussi je suppose en juillet 1944 nous
musulmans madame lesv on s'excuse car
nous sommes allés jusqu'à les accueillir
et les protéger dans notre pays
d'origine ouais et nous sommes opposés à
leur
déportation nous musulmans madame les
viis on s'excuse on s'excuse d'avoir
reconstruit la France des Tron glorieuse
lorsque le pays a été ravagé par la
misère et la famine et pour finir madame
Lévy vous qui êtes esséiste il y a
quelqu'un qui s'appelle Albert Camu que
j'aime beaucoup vous savez qu'il est en
Algérie et il a pratiquement l'un des
mêmes métiers que vous parce que vous
êtes esséiste aussi et il dit que la
bêtise insiste toujours alors il faut
laisser parler voilà bon et ben je vais
peut-être répondre c'est extraordinaire
donc je vous parle de fait tout à fait
concret je vous parle des territoires
perdus de la République je vous dis que
des enfants juifs ont quitté l'école
public et vous m'expliquez que ce sont
les musulmans qui ont sauvé la France
alors je le répète je pense que ça ne
concerne pas tous les musulmans par
ailleurs il y a malgré tout dans
l'histoire des Juifs dans le monde arabe
un certain nombre de pogromes qui ont
précédé donc ça n'est même pas la
question israélienne ils ont précédé la
naissance d'Israël à partir et à partir
du moment où les Juifs n'ont plus été
Dimi alors là c'est devenu une haine
anti-juive qui est repris aujourd'hui
dans l'ensemble du monde arabe et que me
dites-vous qu'il y a des gens
heureusement je le sais il y a
d'excellents français parmi les
musulmans je vous dis jusqu' aujourd'hui
si aujourd'hui si vous êtes sincère je
vous crois sincère alors moi je vous le
dis sincèrement vous devriez vous
inquiéter avec moi au lieu de m'insulter
vous devriez dire ce qui se passe dans
nos banlieux aujourd'hui pour les Juifs
est inacceptable est-ce qu'il est
acceptable pour vous que la synagogue de
trappe est brûlé est-ce qu'il est
acceptable que des Juifs et quittent
l'école publique parce qu'ils sont juifs
et que juifs pour un certain nombre de
de petit de jeunes Français musulmans
c'est une insulte est-ce que vous pouvez
au lieu pour l'humanité parle pas deig
est possible au lie de me parler d'amour
de répondre à
cel euh vous avez pensé quoi de la
lettre de mundir hier euh elle m'a
beaucoup choqué euh déjà j'ai trouvé le
ton assez désastreux c'est-à-dire que
quand on demande à une dame qui
s'appelle léi et qui vient en plus de
visionner 45 minutes d'image atroces sur
les actes terroristes du Hamas du 7
octobre si dascho et la guest ça lui dit
quelque chose bah laissez-moi vous dire
que c'est légèrement sordide mais
au-delà de ça et du ton général
euh bah tout était faux quoi tout était
faux pratiquement ou en tout cas la
quasi totalité était faux alors les
musulmans ont sauvé la France mais je
suis désolé mais faut faut faut
dégonfler son melon quoi à un moment
donné je ne sais pas où vous êtes allé à
l'école ou qui vous a appris ça mais
faut dégonfler son melon les musulmans
n'ont jamais sauvé la France les
musulmans morts euh ça représente 100
les musulmans ça représente 100000 morts
sur les deux guerres mondiales sur les
deux guerres mondiales donc ces gens
sont venus ils sont morts pour la France
et on les on les remercie mais rien qu'à
la Première Guerre mondiale il y a eu
1300000 morts donc les musulmans n'ont
pas sauver la France vous voyez ce que
je veux dire ensuite les musulmans ont
sauvé la France pendant que les Français
étaient chez eux tapis à collaborer mais
vous prenez pour qui mais vous crachez
mais mais sur les Français sur toutes
leur mémoire la collaboration les
historien l'estime entre 2 à 5 % en
France Jean Moulin il est pas né à Rabat
d'accord Charles de Gaulle pareil c'est
un français donc c'est pas les musulmans
qui ont sauvé la France c'est les
Français qui ont sauvé la France et les
Alliés je poursuis quand vous dites que
les Français ont réparé pareil les
Français pardon les musulmans ont réparé
la France pendant les TR glorieuses mais
pendant les 30 glorieuses au pic les les
les comment dire les les étrangers dans
le BTP il représentait 30 % et parmi ces
30 % la majorité était des Italiens et
des Portugais et et des Espagnols et les
les maghrébains donc les musulmans
représentaient ne représentaient en tout
que 6 % de de de des des des gens dans
le
BTP à l'époque des TR glorieus donc
c'est pareil qui est-ce qui vous a
appris que les musulmans ont reconstruit
la France alors que c'est faux et la
dernière chose et après j'arrête quand
on parle d'histoire euh c'est bien vous
pouvez voir la préttenion de parler d'
hisoire et vous avez par exemple vous
avez cité l'imam de la mosquée de Paris
qui effectivement euh aurait sauvé des
Juifs aurait abrité des Juifs mais il
faut parler de tout à ce niveau-là à ce
compte là il faut parler de tout parce
que alors déjà on vous a jamais demandé
de vous excuser ça c'est la première
chose personne ne vous a jamais demandé
de vous excuser et puis vous avez été
très sélectif parce que vous avez jamais
parlé par exemple des 200000 musulmans
en uniforme allemand qu'on a ressenscé
en 43 vous n'avez jamais parlé des
divisions de SS entières composé de
musulmans euh dans les Balcans vous
n'avez pas parlé du moufti de Jérusalem
qui avait des relations très étroites
avec avec Hitler euh et qui a empêché
euh des des milliers de Juifs des pays
de l'Est euh de s'exiler enfin de fuir
en Palestine pour euh pour éviter les
camps et vous avez pas dit euh que dans
tous les pays arabo- mususulmans en ce
moment mcamp fa un Bestseller qui se
vend extrêmement bien bien bien plus
c'est même pas comparable euh que dans
les pays occidentaux et vous n'avez euh
vous l'avez balayé d'un revers de
jamais écoutter ellizabeth Lévi quand
elle vous a dit que depuis 30 ans voire
plus tous les morts tous les morts juifs
tués parce qu'ils sont juifs l'ont été
par la main de musulmans mais je sais
que c'est dur à entendre mais c'est une
simple vérité Koulibali Mera tous nos
attentats myiam knol Sarah limi enfin on
pourrait en citer plein et vous pouvez
pas m'en citer un qui n'a pas à voir
avec avec l'islam mais donc voilà et
encore une fois Elizabeth que vous avez
agressé sans raison n'aveit jamais dit
que tous les musulmans étaient
antisémites elle a dit qu'il y avait un
problème de surreprésentation en ce
moment dans l'islam avec l'antisémitisme
et c'est tout voilà qu'est-ce que tu non
je trouve ça toujours très intéressant
d'être jugé par l'extrême
droite d'ord merci si vous que ça
répondre je je finis je finis mais tous
les deux je vous prends il y a aucun
problème euh alors moi je suis
responsable de ce que je dis mais je
suis pas responss tu dit quoi tous les
deux c'est
qui tous les deux je vous prends pour
quel par toi aussi je te prends donc
pour le pour le coup pour le coup moi je
suis responsable de ce que je dis mais
je suis pas responsable de ce de ce que
les gens pensent donc je je parle en
connaissance de cause je parle d'une
certaine histoire qui a eu lieu
visiblement on n'est pas d'accord
là-dessus en tempant normal je me
mélange jamais avec avec l'extrême
droite je suis allé je vous connaissais
pas je suis allé voir effectivement ce
que vous faisiez je suis tombé sur sur
sur votre profil profil Twitter d'accord
et là je lis en plus vous liké vous avez
liké ça euh donc d'un de vos fans elle a
un plateau d'arabe en face d'elle des
islamistes car oui la majorité des
musulmans en France est islamiste c'est
une minorité qui ne l'est pas bon ça
c'est là-dessus et ensuite il y en a un
autre qui dit
euh et vous avez massacré les nôtres
lors des attentats et vous massacrez les
nôes chaque jour pour envenir à ce que
vous me disiez vis-à-vis de
madame je viens vous faire une
diatritière vous allez répondre à rien
je su juste d'extrême droite c'est tout
non mais attendez je suis en train de
dire vous me dites que j'ai agressé
madame l parle
de est-ce que je peux finir est-ce
répondezli
je je réponds je réponds à ce qu'elle
dit je suis en train de dire que vous me
dites que vous avez que j'ai agressé
madame Levi je n'ai absolument pas
agresser madame Lévi j'ai répondu
justement à une attaque qu'elle dit en
disant qu'elle stigmatise les musulmans
qui sont tous antisém elle a pas dit ça
seu fois une seu fois elle a pas dit ça
une seule fois elle a dit que la
majorité la majorité des elle a dit que
la majorité des fois où les Juifs se
sentaient en danger ça prevenait d'AC
qui venait de gens musulmans et après
elle a dit trois fois pendant le plateau
que elle répétait encore une fois que
tous les musulmans n'étaient pas
antisémites et loin de là c'était une
minorit elle dit elle dit d'accord
vousêtes pas d'accord mais c'est c'est
juste c'est
factuelent je viens de vous exposer ce
soir vous m'avez juste répondu que
j'étais d'extrême droite vous m'or des
tweets de
Random sur Le Rest ça prouve que il y a
des Algériens des indigènes qui sont
venus comb c'est par que vousz vous avez
dit les musulmans ont sauvé la France
pendant que les Français collabor c'est
ça que vous avez dit avz
CCH Mame je n pas craché seulement ça
c'est votre interprétation ce n pas la
dire qu'il y a effectivement des
indigènes musulmans qui ont au péril de
leur vie saué la FR jamais pas une se
fois pas une seule fois laiss m dire
parler non parce que je voulais parler
dire qu'est-ce que tu voulais dire je
dis tout simplement que ceux qui rêvent
qu'il y a une opposition entre les Juifs
de France et les musulmans de France
c'est à eux de quitter la France tout
simplement pardon quoi c'est au français
de quitter la France non je suis en
train de dire ceux qui rêvent ceux qui
rêvent que les juifs et les musulmans
s'entretuentah c'est eux qui n'aiment
pas la France tout simplement c'est pas
la France que je mais qui mais qui rêve
de ça
problème
c'est suis absolument pas àé je suis
absolument pas à côté de la plaque
répond mais je réponds que il me répond
à rien donc je ne sais pas quoi répondre
qu'est-ce que vous voulez répondre vous
avez répondu à rien j'ai jamais dit que
je voulais que les juifs et les
musulmans s'entretuent j'ai jamais dit
qu' avait pas de tirilleur qu' avais pas
de combattant musulmans je les ai même
cité j'ai dit qu'il y en avait eu 100000
mais ce n'était donc pas la majorité
loin de Mor bah si vous avez dit les
musulmans ont sauvé la France alors pas
forcment quand je dis mus bien
évidemment madame est-ce que je peux
est-ce que je peux finir très bien que
je peux
finir absolument pas agressé j'ai été
sur un ton courtois je n'ai absolument
pas le disant à conis non non non j'ai
pas dit ça comme ça remettez lorsque je
dis vous conissz parce que moi ça me
parle d' et et les camp de concentration
ça me parle mais je n'ai pas dit d' Cho
et tout ça Rael
chose écoutez si vous êtes fier de vous
c'est tant mieux juste vous comprenez
les réactions qu' a eu parceil y eu des
réactions des bonnes réaction des
mauvaises réactions sur sur ce qui s'est
passé hier sur la phrase de elabeth Lev
non non de de de de ce qui s'est passé
hier bah oui moi je comprends j'ai été
outré donc je ah oui je vous aviez
tweeté làdessus mais vraiment j'étais
mal à l'aise j'étais mal à l'aise parce
qu'en plus elle est venue je trouve dans
une démarche très honnête et sincère où
elle voulait vraiment faire part d'un
malêtre et c'est le malêtre de la
communauté juive en ce moment et son
malêtre il est il est justifié ou pas
alors ça vous ça je vous laisse
l'apprécier moi je pense que je pense
que oui elle venait de visionner mais 45
minutes d'horreur elle avait encore la
la main qui tremblit ça se VO voyait et
elle s'est fait mais traiter de tous les
noms sur ce plateau de raciste
d'islamophobe et cetera parce qu'elle
une inquiétude et une inquiétude qui est
d'ailleurs beaucoup partagée par les
Juifs qui euh qui qui s'exote par
exemple vous avez jamais dit non plus
que au 20e siècle il y a eu un exode de
800000 Juifs de tous les pays musulmans
qui sont partis j'ai parlé 2 minutes
madame donc j'ai parlé de minutes vous
avez écrit une lettre vousez mais
justement donc je l' donc voilà mais pas
du tout attendez laissez-moi finir moi
j'ai 2 minutes donc j'ai dit ce que
j'avais à dire ce que j'ai dit était
sincère vrai tout simplement à partir du
moment où effectivement il se passe des
choses en France pourquoi tu rigoles
frère c'est lui mon sors j'ai fait quoi
tu sors j'ai rien fait sors oui allez
vas-y tomber mais vas-y
V bien je rassure je trèss bien
e
j'aiépué
dis ce que je
dis j'assume pas Madame répond par faire
plaisir ce que j'assume pas Madame c'est
que vous êtes en train de dire que j'ai
invictimisé madame léy alors que j'aiét
cour en parlant de victime il y a 1500
actes antisémites depuis le 7 octobre et
on a l'impressionou il
a oua y a 1500 actes antisémites depuis
le 7 octobre et si on vous écoute on a
l'impression que les victimes c'est les
musulmans trouvez pas mais vous trouvez
pas ça hier hier vous nous avez fait à
larmes enfin c'était des larmes à larmes
vous étiez là en train de nous expliquer
comment les
musulmans hér et Vitim j si je peux
permettre de parler pour b b en fait ce
qui ce qu'il voulait dire je pense hier
et ce qu'il veut dire aujourd'hui c'est
que lui il veut pas que le comme l'a dit
gérardmanin que le le
conflit s'exporte ici et que lui il a
pas envie que ce soit la guerre entre
les musulmans les Juifs entre ses potes
entre sa famille puce qu'il a de la
famille c'est ce que c'est ce qu'a voulu
dire mundir je pense que c'est ça qu'
voulait dire c'est pour ça que je dis je
dis ceux qui veulent opposer c'est ça
que je voulais dire bien évid et ceux
qui veulent opposer les Juifs de France
et les musulmans de France non madame
pardonnez-mo év bien é qui passe Act
passe actuellement ce qui se passe
actuellement on veut opposer deux
communautés qui son très très bien si
Madame vousêes pas sur le terrain on
sent très très bien sentend très très
bien il faut voyager un petit peu et
vous
verzs
bien pale en israëlent pas très bienil
pour parce y a des musulmans mal de pas
nom les choses arrêtez de dire très bien
vous mais moi ici j'ai dénoncé j'ai
dénoncé et je fais des choses je pas
vous dire bravo c'est des ch je su pas
en train de vous dire bravo alors mais
arrêtez de me dire qu'il y a aucun
problème entre les Juifs et les
musulmans en ce moment ça relève vent y
a un grave problème à Gaza et en Israël
pas du tout donc les 1500 actes
depuis létimité a des il faut les condam
et il faut les punè mais maintenant
l'ensemble des Juifs français et
l'ensemble des musulmans musul fr
s'entend très très bien dire sur la
phrase d'hier tu te sens pas mal à
l'aise sur laquelle le fait de dire à
elisabeth Lévy d'O de demander à à
quelqu'un s'il connaitt guestapo
guestapo eto juste cette phrase là
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui alors
je te réponds par que tu me fais le même
coup qu'avec l'imam lorsque je dis à
Isabelle Lévi madame l Elisabeth pardon
éisabeth Lévi lorsque je lui dis est-ce
que dascho ça vous parle c'est parce que
ça me parle d'accord voilà je pense ça
lu parle beaucoup aussi par quand on
s'app Tu Vi tu viens de haer tu viens tu
viens de hausser la tête ça prouve que
finalement tu me crois pas mais je suis
en train de dire quand je parle de
dascho ça me parle et les quand de la
mort ça me parle je dis pas que ça te
parle pas non mais moi c'était ça quand
je dis est- que ça parle par j'
dire pas
très c'est çaur pu dire ça me parle
est-ce que ça vous parle comme moi ça me
parle c'est peut-être çaa arrangé c'est
ça ah le dire comme ça ça n'a rien à
voir c'est comme ça je soule un DEP tout
àheure pouroi j'ai juste soufflé parce
que monsieur di il part très très
mal l'accuser tout de suite d'extrême
droite avec ce qu'elle a dit avec
beaucoup de vérité j'ai voilà c'est pour
ça donc si tu l'as mal pris excuse-moi
juste en revanche je trouve que tu as
été prêt je crois ta sincérité je crois
en ta sincérité il y a pas de problème
je pense que hier ce que tu as fait
c'est exactement ce que tu reprochais à
éliizabeth Lévi qui pose un vrai
problème ça se discute mais elle pose un
vrai problème en disant que il y a un
problème d'antisémitisme avec les
musulmans il y a pas que les néonazis de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale et Jean-Marie
Le Pen qui pose un problème en ce moment
d'antisémitisme c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut mettre sur la table elle a
choqué hier mais c'était bien qu'elle
choc et et toi tu lui disais qu'elle
elle globalisait et que tous les
musulmans étaient antisémit tu et là tu
fais exactement pareil dans ta lettrre
tu as fait exactement pareil nous
musulmans on a sauvé la France pendant
que la majorité des Français collaborai
tu fais exactement la même choseement
Daniel j'ai étis à l'inverse j'aiété à
l'inverse quand je dis nous musulmans on
s'excuse c'est justement pour dire que
tous les musulmans en France ne sont pas
antisémites et la France n'est pas tombé
en 3 jours pardon la France n'est pas
tombée en 3 jours ni en qure d'accord
mais vous avez dit la France est tombé
en 3
jours et le Bliss c'est juste
une oui c'est une guerre rapide c'est
mais la France n'est pas tombé en 3
jours peu importe d'accord la drôle de
guerre elle a duré 8 mois enfin voilà
donc non mais en
fait ça fait pas des Français
littéralement rien à retenir de vrai
dans tout ce que vous avez dit de toute
votre diatrip pourtant vous l'avz écrite
pourant vous l'aviez écrit voyz moi j'ai
même pas de
note il y a un élément qui est vrai
c'est que la la la Grande Mosquée de
Paris a sauvé 1732 Ju 1732 Juifs 1732
Juifs pendant d'ailleurs je suis en
train d'essayer de minimiser les bonnes
actions des musulmans qui sont morts
pour la France ou qui se sont se sont
battus avec vérité pour la France mais
c'est pas du tout mon mon projet par
contre vous par contre vous vous avez
effacé tout ce qu'on fait
les vous savez monsieur
pour Tux qui sont mors sur la France
pour son fr qui passe sur les plaques
commémoratives dans les villages il y a
pas écrit mundir 100 fois vraiment non
vous dis vousz musulmans ont sauvé la
France bah moi je vois je vois pas
beaucoup de
mundir enc une fois redescendons il
s'agit pas encore une fois de minimiser
les actes héroïques des musulmans qui
sont mors pour la France AZ tout notre
histoire on le cche fr mais votre hisire
votre histoire c'est mon hisire auss
franchement voilà c'était AB je vous le
dis c'était AB et et ça vraiment ça a
choqué tout le monde et
moiis mal à l'ISE mal àise de
VO elle savait même pas qu quo par
placeil vous parle pas frchement vous
lui devz des excuses truc non mais je
suis un
peu je suis un peu dégoûté par Madame
mais respectueusement parce qu'on prend
un cours d'histoire de votre
part qui émane effectivement
d'une partie de l'extrême droite qui est
extrêmement vindicatif pourre les
musulmans d'autre part la Seu erreur de
mundir ce sont les chiffres que vous
avez repris d'accord mais là vous êtes
en train de faire ce que fait madame non
mais vous êtes en train de faire ce que
fait madame Lévy c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
vous minorez totalement le rôle des
musulmans pendant la guerre vous êtes en
train d'effacer vous l'histoire des
musulmans en France mais si c'est ce que
vous faites vous savez très bien que
derrière laabé
derè j'ai même pas un mot
derrière l'habileté de votre rhtorique
il y a les 100000 musulmans on les
efface les Marocains qui ont libéré la
Corse en 1943 on s'en fout vous êtes en
train de balayer l'apport et l'impact
des musulmans en France au nom de vos
croyances et ça c'est dégueulasse que
vous faites à mir c'est
dégueulass RPé je l'ai répété au moins
trois fois il ne s'agit absolument pas
de minorer les actes héroïques de tous
ces musulmans qui sont morts pour la
France répéterz répéz trois fois et là
vous me dites vous ok bon alors en fait
rien à vous dire Monsieur si vouscoutez
pas vous
direextrême droite j'ai juste dit ma
vérité et une vérité en fait factuelle
parce que contrairement à Monsieur je
connais mon histoire et puis c'est tout
quoi en fait j'ai rien dit d'extrême
droite r que vous avez lui dire à part
ça tout est faux dans ce qu'elle dit c
elle manipule tout elle prend TR
chiffres c'est vrai c'est une c'est une
phraséologie d'ext elle va dire bientôt
elle a minimisé totalement le rôle des
alliés pendant la libération c'estd que
pour vous ce sont les français qui sont
révoltés contre l'allem vous avez cité
les chiffres des collaborationnistes
100000 on est d'accord entre 2 et 5 %
mais ce sont les alliés qui nous ont
sauvé mais si mais vous savez très bien
vous réécrivez l'histoire à l'OND de vos
croyant sauvé non plus c'est pas plus
les musulmans que les non musulmans mais
c'est pas MOS les musulans te trompe sur
un point c'est que c'est les réseaux
catholiques qui étaient les plus
puissants en matière de de résistance et
qui ont organiser une partie de la
résistance les communistes évidemment
mais les réseau le réseau catholique via
les diocèses via via tout le tout tout
tout le tout ce qui était en place les
écoles les religieux et cetera bien plus
que d'autres
confessions pour finir non mais pour
finir voilà moi je je suis venu dire ma
vérité défendre ellzabeth Levi aussi
parce que vraiment j'ai été touchée j'ai
été touchée par le le traitement qu'elle
a reçu ici j'ai trouvé que j'ai trouvé
totalement inje et voilà et donc pour
termin qui lui a manqué de respect ici
mais tu étais là qui qui lui a manqué de
respect
ici qui lui a manqué de respect î nous
nous quand on est on était sur le
plateau on l' pas ça mais a préori éé ce
qui a été ressenti c'est qu'il y avait
une meute contre elle contre Elisabeth l
qui é ceux qui étent contre elle qui ont
parl exactement c'est ça parce que
Elisabeth elle est
tellement de rien est tellement forte
que j' me dit voilà pris islamophobe et
raciste dans la tête quand
même il a eu l'impression qu'il y avait
que des gens qui étaient contre
Elisabeth lev mais comme j'ai fait
parler que ceux qui étaient contre
Elisabeth l parce que forcément
Elisabeth leviiss défendre tout seul
forcément ça a donné l'impression d'un
plateau hostile contre
elle je devais faire un dîner avec mon
copain justement donc j'étais juste
partie acheter ce que je devais
justement cuisiner et cetera et en fait
ce qui s'est passé c'est que je suis
rentrée j'étais au Monoprix dans le 17e
donc à 10 minutes à pied de chez moi qui
est aussi entre l'agression qui s'était
passé juste avant marcher seul
tranquille marcher seul tranquille
j'avais même pas mes écouteurs et en
fait juste j'ai ouvert mon hall de chez
moi alors est-ce que vous sentiez suivi
pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout j'ai
rien entendu vraiment rien du tout vous
sentez pas du tout suivi vous revenez
des courses vous avez des courses vous
avez des paquets dans j'avais juste un
petit sac Monoprix et une bouteille de
vin d'accord donc vous aviez un petit
dîner vous préparer un petit dîner donc
on est dans le 8e arrondissement de
Paris qui est assez fréquenté en plus
avec beaucoup de passages c'est ça qui
est exactement il y a énormément de
monde énormément de monde dans les rues
dans après ma rue est assez calme donc
comme c'était le 11 novembre aussi
peut-être que les person on était parti
en weekend mais je pense que enfin oui
donc là vous vous vous sentez rien de de
de de de particulier vous rentrez donc
dans dans dans votre h d'immeuble vous
faites un code vous avez un code ou bien
c'est oui justement enfin j'ai fait le
code et juste la porte est très très
lourde à ouvrir et se referme très
lentement d'accord et j'étais en train
de marcher et j'ai senti quelque chose
qui m'a fait plaquer au sol ah donc en
fait vous rentrez et vous sentez tout de
suite que vous êtes plaqué au sol
exactement et là je me fais enfin
attraper justement et
couper la respiration donc je comprends
pas trop ce qui se passe au début et
après pendant 10 minutes vraiment je me
débat je crie personne m'entend alors
vous êtes là vous êtes dans le H
d'immeuble vous sentez donc quelqu'un
vous arrivez à à vous retourner vous
voyez la la personne pas du tout parce
que enfin céit une personne quand même
qui était assez forte je pense qu'il
faisait au moins 1,85 assez costaud avec
une capuche en plus donc j'ai rien vu au
début et qui vraiment m'agrippé le
visage comme ça et il vous a agripé le
visage il vous étrangle il m'étrangle il
m'étouffe il me coupe la respiration
aussi donc il vous vous êtes à terre à
terre du coup oui il était au-dessus de
moi vous vous essayez de crier vous
arrivez à crier quand même ou pas au
début j'arrive à crier sauf que je vois
que je m'étouffe entre guillemets de
plus en plus donc juste je me dis que
c'est un peu compliqué et puis en plus
il me fait des menaces de mort qu'est-ce
qu'il vous dit il me dit je vais te tuer
chute tais-toi je vais te
tuer il vous dit ce qu' ce qu' veut ce
qu'il veut tout de suite ou pas du tout
au début non pensez à quoi au début
pense à quoi estce que là là je me dis
vous rentz de course vous vous retrouvez
plaqué au sol agressé vous pensez à quoi
ce momentl vous dites c'est quoi vous
dites c'est il veut quoi au début je me
dis qu'il veut juste me enfin me voler
entre guillemets et que bah il va juste
prendre mon sac et mon téléphone et que
enfin ça s'en finira et en fait au final
il commence à me dire que il veut plus
il vous dit quoi il me dit tu vas faire
ce que je te dis maintenant et tu vas
arrêter de crier
et du coup enfin je vais te
baiser euh là bien sûr vous on va pas
rentrer dans les détails bien sûr bien
sûr
euh qu'est-ce qui donc là il il a il
arrive à ses fin il bah du coup en fait
j'essaie de me débattre pendant une
dizaine de minutes je vois que c'est un
peu peine perdu et que pour sauver ma
peau le seul moyen c'était que justement
je fasse ce qu'ils veulent donc
justement enfin pendant 20 minutes après
il y a eu il y a eu viol et et pendant
ce tempsl en fait je me suis un peu
dissocié de mon corps et je me suis dit
il faut que je trouve toutes les
solutions possibles pour pouvoir en tout
cas partir et enin juste quitter cet
endroit quoi c'est cauchemar il dure 20
minutes 30 minutes 30 minutes mais
personne ne rentre et ne sort de
l'immeuble non et là vous voyez ça fait
que 10 minutes qu'on se parle et c'est
toujours pas fini le viol non non mais
je vous jure c'est c'est c'est
incroyable et personne personne ne
rentre ni ne sort de l'immeuble pendant
ces 30 minutes non vous vous vous criez
plus moment vous vous cris plus parce
que je sais que enfin je sais pas
pourquoi je sentais qu'il avait
peut-être une arme sur lui j'ai entendu
des bruits un peu de métal et je me suis
juste dit ok bah sauve ta peau et en
attendant qu' a quelqu'un qui arrive
fait ce qu'il dit vous aviez peur de de
de de le de de le frapper de de lui de
le voilà de de trop crier à un momentù
vous êtes dit ça va être pire exactement
je me suis dit que juste il fallait
mieux rien dire il était où il était où
votre copain à ce moment-là euh bah il
était chez lui il était censé arriver
l'heure d'après quoi et donc là ce qui
est F je vous dis c'est incroyable une
demiheure personne qui rentre dans le
dans dans dans dans le dans le hall de
l'immeuble euh qu'est-ce que vous vous
dites à ce momentl vous dites la seule
manière de m'en sortir c'est quoi parce
que est-ce que vous vous vous dites je
vais il va me tuer ou est-ce que vous
dites non c'est je vais faire ce qu'il
me dit et peut-être qu'il va partir
après non je pensais que après qu'il ait
eu ses faims aussi enfin qu'
littéralement me tue euh donc je me suis
dit qu'en fait j'allais attendre le
moment où il il était capable de entre
guillemets lâcher prise pour pouvoir
justement partir et m'échapper alors
justement qu'est qu'est-ce qui se passe
parce que
comment qu'est-ce qu'il vous dit quand
quand il s'en va qu'est-ce qu'il vous
dit comment quand vous sentez que bon il
va il va partir et que vous allez
survivre à ce à ce drame euh du coup en
fait il y a une il y a une voisine qui
descend de l'immeuble et qui ouvre la
porte et qui nous voit et moi en fait le
moment où il tourne la tête je savais
très bien où était mon sac et mon
téléphone je me suis dit j'ai besoin de
mon téléphone pour appeler la police
j'ai besoin de mon sac pour rentrer chez
moi donc je cours vers mon sac et mon
téléphone pour les récupérer et juste je
vais derrière la voisine et lui à ce
moment-là part prend la
fuite là là vous êtes dans quel état à
ce momentl avec la voisine avec bah dans
un état j'avais plein de sang sur moi
aussi parce que du coup j'avais une
bouteille de vin qui s'est éclaté par
terre donc j'ai essayé de me débattre
d'où le le pansement là où j'ai dû me
faire opérer et cetera après en plus
et en fait ce qui s'est passé juste bah
j'ai commencé à dire à la voisine que je
me faisaisoler je pleurais excusez-moi
parce qu'on a pas entendu par justuse
que enfin je me faisais violer du coup
et au début elle comprenait pas et en
fait le seul enfin son seul objectif
c'était de prendre son ber pour partir
en voyage quoi elle vous dit quoi la
voisine que c'est incroyable ça aussi
écoute vous lui dites je viens de me
faire violer vous êtes dans un état vous
saignez vous êtes dans un état de de
forcément de de
de de choc ch incroyable et elle vous
dit quoi elle vous prend pour une folle
elle dit quoi au début elle croyait que
c'était juste une scène d'amour ah oua
et j'étais là mainten non vous voyez
bien que enfin je suis à moitié nu enfin
c'est ça va pas du tout en fait je
commence à pleurer et du coup elle me
donne juste son numéro pour entre
guillemets que je l'appelle après elle a
été vraiment enin sur son uber et elle
voulait absolument prendre son uber donc
elle m'a juste laissé son numéro elle
m'a dit de prendre de la vitamine D
aussi et après c'est serviable c'est fou
mais est-ce que est-ce que vous avez vu
l'individu à un moment est-ce que vous
avez pu le voir ressemblit à quoi donc
grand bon parce que maintenant il a été
arrêté mais est-ce que vous avez pu voir
son visage à un moment ou pas du tout
justement j'ai fait en sorte d'analyser
tout pour pouvoir repérer le plus
d'éléments possible et oui j'ai analysé
qu'il avait une griffure sur le visage
et que enfin il mesurait temps de temps
de maître corpulence et cetera les
vêtements c'estàdire que quand vous
viviez ce cauchemar vous pensez à tout
ça vous dites il faut que j'ai le plus
d'éléments possibles pour pouvoir
ensuite qu'on puisse appréander ce ce
cet individu exactement en plus il
m'avait dit que il me disait des choses
comme quoi j'allais rien dire à personne
et que j'allais me taire sinon ça all
êre encore plus grave après donc euh
ensuite euh qu'est-ce qui se passe après
parce que
euh les minutes sont des heures
forcément au bout de 30 minutes euh donc
votre agresseur part euh bien sûr vous
êtes vous êtes soulagé mais à quoi vous
pensez à ce
moment-là je me dis ouf déjà d'accord et
premier réflexe c'est enin du coup la
voisine qui me laisse comme ça donc là
vous vous retrouvez seul dans le r seul
et puis en fait je rentre dans mon
appartement du coup ouais et je
m'enferme à double tour et premier
réflexe j'appelle mon copain pour qu'il
vienne plus rapidement possibleoi votre
copain par que là vous vous devez vous
êtes quoi vous l'appelez vous êtes dans
quel état vous vous criez vous lui dites
il m'est arrivé une horreur juste il m'
quelque chose de très grave viens tout
de suite je viens de me faire violer
quoi et agresser vous dit quoi il me dit
ok j'arrive mais il comprend pas
forcément ce qui se passe donc et là
quand il arrive vous il vous trouve bah
en attendant enfin j'avais déjà appelé
la police et cetera qui était déjà sur
place donc le temps qu'il arrive enfin
c'est déjà bien encadré et cetera mais
ouais donc vous appelez la police
j'appelle la police qui arrive dans les
10 minutes qui suivent donc franchement
la police a été incroyable encore et ils
l'ont interpellé très vite après
d'ailleur aussi exactement et donc la
police vous faire quoi police très bien
encadré ça ça a duré plus de 72 heures
entre retour chez les médecins les tests
et cetera chez l'UMJ en même temps la
police judiciaire la déposition et
cetera mais non ils ont vraiment été
très fort là-dessus et en plus comme ils
ont comme ils l'ont retrouvé enfin juste
parfait vous êtes donc opéré le
lendemain parce que vous êtes débattu
vous êtes blessé au doigt à cause de
votre votre bouteille de vin aujourd'hui
on est 5 jours après ce terrible
drame vous êtes dans quel état parce
qu'on on trouve que je trouve que vous
êtes très très fort et vraiment que vous
arrivez à en parler
avec un détachement incroyable tout à
l'heure vous n avez dit en fait j'ai
essayé de sortir de mon corps est-ce que
vous réalisez après 5 jours ou pas
encore je pense pas encore c'est ça
parce que je sais que c'est un peu mon
inconscient qui parle parce que il parle
que quand je dors et là je fais des
cauchemars et cetera mais sinon dans la
vraie vie je suis forte je pleur pas
vous n'arrivez plus à dormir non enfin
je suis obligé de prendre les somnifères
donc vous pensez à quoi enfin vous rêvez
de quoi vous cauchemar de quoi vous
revoyez le le visage
de l'agresseur ou pas du le visage oui
et puis surtout enfin l'agressement et
enfin le fait que je suis en train
d'étouffer et de me faire
tuer vous sortez plus seul j'imagine non
j'ai beaucoup de mal voà aujourd'hui
quoi vous regardez tout le temps
derrière vous vous êtes tout le temps
j'appelle tout le temps des gens quand
je suis dehors je peux pas rentrer toute
seule chez moi je peux pas rester plus
d'une heure toute seule non plus sinon
enfin je commence à repenser à ce qui
s'est
passé avec votre copain quand il il
habite il habite chez vous désormais
pour le moment oui temporairement du
coup parce que un peu compliqué comment
il a trouvé les mots aussi parce que
c'est il vous a dit quoi il m'a vraiment
beaucoup rassuré et il a vraiment été là
pour moi de A à Z il m'a accompagné à
tous les rendez-vous et cetera mais
enfin après il y a pas grand chose à
dire non plus c'est fait c'est fait et
on y est pour rien et c'est comme ça le
lendemain vous apprenez dans la presse
que votre agresseur n'aurait pas dû être
là h puisqu'il était sous au qtf
obligation de de quitter le territoire
Fran
euh comment vous réagissez est-ce que ça
vous énerve encore plus oui forcément ça
m'énerve après je pense que un viol
c'est pas forcément que un cttf ça peut
être n'importe qui mais c'est vrai que
ça rajoute une colère en plus en sachant
que bah il était censé quitter le
territoire et aujourd'hui bah il a
plutôt enin violé le territoire entre
guillemets donc enfin c'est assez
énervant et je me dis que c'est je suis
pas la première et que il faudrait avoir
vraiment des mesures un peu plus rad
pour pouvoir il vous parlait
beaucoup un petit peu oui il m'a demandé
aussi de pouvoir rentrer chez moi ah
ouais donc j'aurais pu me faire
séquestrer aussi s'il avait regardé un
petit peu dans mon sac les clés et
cetera et plus vous lui disiez quoi
quand vous quand il vous a dit je ve
rentrer chez toi je disais en non j'ai
mes parents qui habitent chez moi c'est
pas possible bien ouais vous avez vous
avez réussi à quand même à à garder une
lucidité pour pouvoir euh répondre des
des des choses qui puissent peut-être
vous sauver la vie vous avez pensé qu'à
ça sauver votre vie à ce moment-là
exactement euh clair je je je crois que
vous voulaz dire aussi un mot sur sur
les viols parce que qui sont trop
souvent banalisés certains dit associe
uniquement le viol à la à la
pénétration vous aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
que vous aimeriez dire parce que votre
histoire voilà elle a glacé tout le
monde c'est un témoignage très important
parce qu'on on veut pas que ça se
reproduise et vous aussi vous voulez pas
que ça se reproduise et c'est très
courageux de voir votre part clair
d'être là ce soir qu'est-ce que vous
vouliez dire je veux juste dire que en
fait le viol enfin pourontextualiser
c'est un acte non consenti pénétration
que ça soit prénétration orale ou juste
digitale et juste que en fait même une
main baladeuse c'est aussi ça peut être
considéré aussi comme un viol et que
enfin faut un peu se remettre en
question les hommes ils sont pas permis
de tout et les hommes aussi peufin ou
les femmes entre guillemets tout le
monde peu réaliser un viol et juste il y
a beaucoup de femmes qui n'en parlent
pas aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça aussi
que je prends la parole aujourd'hui
parce que que j'ai envie de parler pour
les femmes et de leur dire que juste
enin il faut en parler il y a des
numéros il y a des associations et juste
pouvoir se libérer vous allez pensez que
vous allez pouvoir revivre normalement
ou vous êtes inquiète de ça non
forcément je suis inquiète ouais après
je pense que il faut démocratiser la
chose et je vais essayer au maximum d'en
parler pour pouvoir me libérer aussi ça
vous fait du bien d'en parler bien sûr
vous y pensez tout le
temps bah c'est un peu le sujet
d'actualité tous les jours donc
j'essayie 5 jours après est-ce que vous
avez pour vous déjà évoluer est-ce que
vous avez
déjà voilà évoluer dans votre vie tous
les jours ou est-ce que vous êtes
toujours dans le dans le même état ou
est-ce que vous dites pas peut-être que
je vais avoir une très grosse redescente
dans dans dans quelques jours mais je
pense qu'en fait le viol c'est pendant
l'acte et c'est aussi après l'acte
et apparemment c'est le plus dur après
même 6 mois après c'est encore pire
parce qu'on se sent de plus en plus seul
il y a beaucoup moins de gens qui nous
entourent aussi les aour oubl s ouis et
moi j'espère que ça va aller mieux mais
c'est vrai
que voulez à qui
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui en soit enfin peut-être à la
justice qui a pas fait son travail pour
ça en tout cas à l'état aussi parce
qu'il aurait dû être enenvoyé
après enin est-ce que je peux en vooir à
quelqu'un particulièrement oui à
l'agresseur sûrement bien sûr quand vous
avez appris qu'il avait été arrêté vous
avez été soulagé bien sûr heureusement B
vous avez vous êtes dit fait quoi oui et
puis en plus on se sent pas forcément
enfin je me sens moins seule parce que
du coup la fille qui était avant moi
aussi enfin ACU la même chose vous êtes
parl oui on s'est parlé et
important ça aussi c'est très important
parce qu'on sent soud du coup donc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
exactement